le couperet est tombé après des semaines
d'attentes l'ancien président de la
république nicolas sarkozy vient d'être
condamné ce matin à trois ans de prison
dont un an ferme
ça veut dire que la justice considère
que nicolas sarkozy oui a bien tenté de
comprendre magistrats c'est bien ça que
ça va être la raison l' affaire des
écoutes téléphoniques dans laquelle
nicolas sarkozy sous la fausse identité
de paul bismuth aurait établi un pacte
de corruption avec son avocat maître
thierry herzog et l'ancien haut
magistrat gilbert azibert aujourd'hui
l'ancien chef de l'état ne risque pas
pour autant d'aller en prison étant
donné qu'avec une peine de un an il a la
possibilité d'aménager sa peine en
portant par exemple un bracelet
électronique
son avocate a annoncé que nicolas
sarkozy allait faire appel de ces
décisions de justice
alors la condamnation de nicolas sarkozy
est elle trop sévère merci à pierre
farges d'être avec nous avocats
pénalistes vous savez que chaque fois
que vous venez sur ce plateau
tiffany bonvoisin voilà est très
heureuse merci mais il est avant tout
avocat qu'il faut le lâcher il a du
travail
merci pierre farc d'être là et merci à
olivier marc l'ex d'être avec nous vos
députés les républicains vice-président
et l'air ancien conseiller nicolas
sarkozy merci d'être avec moi alors
d'abord je voudrais faire un petit tour
de table et je ne m'adressais d'abord à
stéphane tapis je sais que connaît
connaissez bien le dossier
enfin je connais est ce que vous trouvez
que c'est trop sévères pour ces nids
sévère ni pas trop sévère on parle enfin
c'est pas un dossier comme les autres
qu'on parle du président de la
république qui est condamné après c'est
un dossier où on en est qu'à la première
mi temps il ya une deuxième mi temps
après il y aura sûrement une cassation
donc est ce que la sanction est sévère
j'ai pas mis le nez dans le dossier un
petit peu comme tout le monde
donc non par rapport aux faits et notre
avocat pourra vous confirmer on risque
jusqu'à dix ans de prison sur une
affaire comme celle-ci par rapport aux
réquisitions qui avait été fait
où il avait été demandé deux ans ferme
ce que l'autre sur six était surtout
deux ans ferme histoire de bien être sûr
que ça soit de la prison là dont on
parle il faut pas et on parle du
président donc là on n'est pas en train
de parler de loana de autre chose on
parle du président de la république donc
est ce que c'est
c'est sévère non si les faits celui
sombrait sont avérées pardon et mais
voilà c'est le début c'est on est au
tout tout tout début de l'histoire nous
quand on quand on voit ça de l'extérieur
on connaît pas trop bien le dossier
mais voilà m est-ce que vous pensez que
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous pensez que la peine est trop sévère
alors moi je connais pas le dossier
s'est pas eu accès au dossier
je donne mon avis comme un faux pas je
suis un justiciable pourrait connais un
petit peu les arcanes judiciaires
moi je pense que nicolas sarkozy a été
jugé sur des faits présumés de
corruption qui ne trouve pas un début
d'exécution et deuxième point que ces
éléments ont été obtenus dans le cadre
de d'ecoute il est loyal écouter des
avocats
à aider écouter intercepté des
conversations entre un avocat et un
client c'est servir pour l'autre une
base
normalement non c'est comme ça la cour
de cassation s'est prononcée la
profession a été vendeuse vous sur ces
procédés c'est peut-être ça qu'on
pourrait considérer qu'il s'agit d'un
d'un procès politique mais remettre en
cause le secret professionnel qui est
absolu normalement entre un avocat et
son client
c'est porter atteinte à l'état de droit
c'est remettre en cause les principes ce
principe démocratique qui est inscrit
dans notre constitution
alors olivier willocx vous quand vous
avez appris la décision aujourd'hui quel
était votre action est dit c'est trop
sévère oui oui bien sûr un peu un peu
estomaqué par par la lourdeur quand même
de cette de cette décision nicolas
sarkozy annonce à présent de la
république il n'est pas au dessus des
lois
on est bien d'accord avec ça si déjà
droit il a droit comme tous les
politiques il a droit quand même un
procès équitable comme comment vous ça
n'a pas été le cas mais dans cette
affaire dont il ya beaucoup de choses
qui pose problème
vous avez vous et vous avez quand même
le fait que le le parquet le parc
national financier après des années
d'investigations n'a pas été capable
d'amener une preuve il n'y avait pas de
preuves il y avait juste une intuition
ne soit pas et ensuite vous n'avez pas
de où le délit n'a pas été commis
lui-même
donc il est jugé nicolas sarkozy vrai
l'annoncions l'intuition d'une intention
mais qui d'autre en france et est puni
de peines de prison pour l'intention
d'avoir commis un délit ça n'existe pas
donc oui effectivement il n'ya pas de
y'a pas de cave en quelques traits c'est
le rêve sur l'intuition enfin
l'attention de fait de commettre un
délit
j'ai pas de commettre un crime on parle
d'art on parle d'un chien c'est quand
même une sévérité extrême et puis
ensuite les conditions de cette enquête
qui ont été quand même assez
extravagante sept mois sept mois d'
écoute 24 heures sur 24 qui en france a
le droit à un tel régime de cette mode
écoute des terroristes en général non
non ils n'ont pas autant de 2,2 de
surveillance que ça donc on a eu quand
même une
ensuite toute une instruction à charge
tout est affaire concerne nicolas
sarkozy sont confiées aux mêmes
magistrats
où est le sentiment qu'il peut avoir le
justicier
d'avoir à faire un juge équitable
lorsque tous les dossiers sont confiées
par le même magistrat
le troisième quatrième cinquième fois
que vous le voyez vous avez vous le
sentiment d'avoir affaire à un juge
un juge équitable et qui regardent le
dossier avec indépendance nicholas pardi
comme vous dites oui vous aussi je dis
oui pour une raison simple c'est que
aujourd'hui deux avocats qui se parlent
ensemble sur n'importe quelle affaire
n'ont pas le droit de communiquer leurs
discussions pour l'un ou l'autre des
témoins nous y trompons l'occurrence
brassac est un mais attention attention
en l'occurrence là ils ont été écoutés
donc cet effet à leur insu et ça a été
utilisée est exploité donc c'est un
véritable scandale parce que ça va
remettre toutes les affaires en l'air
pour des particuliers ou pour ou des
gens lambda comme nous donc ça à vrai
scandale
la question nicolas sarkozy doit pour
l'instant se serait un enfer est ce que
ça veut dire faire appel oui bien sûr si
la décision est confirmée
est ce que ça voudrait dire c'est ça la
vraie question qui se pose est est
spectateur nous voilà on est est ce que
va dire nicolas sarkozy peut mais on
passe et non au présent c'est la
question il faut la poser bien sûr il
n'y a pas de justice à deux vitesses et
non comme tout le monde condamne et même
à un an ferme si on appelle il est
recondamné il n'ira pas en prison
c'est un aménagement de peine et
d'ailleurs la présidente donc ça veut
dire quoi il fera quoi alors la
présidente du tribunal lui a proposé
aujourd'hui dès la fin de l'audience si
vous ne faites pas appel je vous propose
d'avoir chez vous un pass l'électronique
ça d'accord voilà c'est à dire n'aurait
nicolas sarkozy qu'un passé pour les
politiciens dans la manche et lui il
aurait pu mais comme il a fait appel
voilà tout est remis à zéro évidemment
alors est ce qu'il pourrait se
représenter aux élections avec un pass
électronique ou pas du tout impossible
il n'y a pas de peine d'inégibilité qui
avait encore avancé ça paraît quand même
difficile même avec l'appel qu'il puisse
rentrer de nouveau dans le jeu politique
mais techniquement il n'y a pas
d'impossibilité juridique ce qui est
étrange dans cette affaire c'est qu'ils
avaient en plus qui ironie du sort
twittait ya quelques années pour dire
qu'il était contre l'aménagement des
peines de moins de six mois
donc en fait il était content que le
bracelet électronique à la maison dans
son cas précis mais monsieur pardon vous
pensez pas qu'en tant que président de
la république malgré tout il est le
garant des institutions et
l'indépendance de la justice et qui ne
se doit d'être encore plus exemplaire et
que ne serait-ce que l'intuition c'est
déjà trop oui l'intention l'intention
oui plutôt
non mais c'est ce que dit la décision de
la justice ce que vous
que vous récitez très bien voilà sauf
qu'une fois encore nicolas sarkozy l'a
eue quand même à charge contre lui à
parc national financier créé par
françois hollande qui est une
monstruosité juridique en soi pardon de
le dire mais cette fois c'est le pnf il
a le droit de faire de récupérer le
contrôle de toutes les affaires politico
financières dans le pays si ça ça vous
choque pas pardon ça me choque
on a la possibilité d'aider jeunesse du
canard enchaîné d'ailleurs qui a écrit
un livre sur sur françois hollande et à
l'elysée s'appelait bienvenue place
beauvau mairie racontait comment on
pouvait ralentir le feu sur une
casserole ou au contraire c'est-à-dire
accéléré sur d'autres c'est à dire quand
nicolas hollande pour qui françois
hollande voilà je vous dis pour les
téléspectateurs
quand il était président en beauce et du
ministère de l'intérieur il pouvait
accélérer des affaires laissées des
dossiers un peu en dessous de la pile
pour qu'il soit traité un petit peu plus
tard c'est ce que disait un peu ce livre
1 du canard enchaîné balade de deux
auteurs du carnage à nos listes et qui
est c'est vrai que toute la question que
se posent les téléspectateurs et qu'on
se pose ici c est ce qu on a voulu
pénaliser nicolas sarkozy essayez un
président se le mette souhaité noir pour
se dire il ya une élection qui va
arriver en 2022 et nicolas sarkozy
serait peut-être un candidat sérieux y
allant lui alors lui je le dis nicolas
sarkozy n'a jamais dit que voulait se
représenter vraiment je vous dis même
dans les voilà ils ont un truc j'ai
jamais entendu qu'on me dise nicolas
sarkozy veut se présenter mais l'entente
aura peut-être le honorable quoi
l'andorran l'entourage peut pas
actuellement à droite préféré des
français
à droite il est le principal opposant
putatif du président de la république
donc c'est un homme qui compte
incontestablement la veille des
présidents solide et oui il compte mais
c'est surtout l'entourage qui voudrait
que nicolas sarkozy qui s'est dit à
nicolas sarkozy que je n'y suis pas il
faut que tu y ailles c'est toi l'homme
de la situation
maintenant c'est à toi d'y aller et
c'est vrai que lui on l'a jamais entendu
dire j'ai envie d'y aller donc pour
l'instant donc mais est ce que on sait
pas dit comme c'est ce que voilà ce
qu'on sait pas dire un moment il faut
peut-être le mettre hors jeu
aussi je pose toutes les questions
questions furent posées carrés sur les
réseaux sociaux
bernard montiel un porte parole du
gouvernement
vous dire nicolas sarkozy il est très
fédérateur à droite
tout le monde rêve que ce soit lui qui
se présente lui ne veut pas se présenter
après plus d'informations et je vais
vous dire la situation dans laquelle il
est il est beaucoup plus fort parce
qu'il conseille un peu tout le monde je
vois ma vie bertrand lui court un peu
après pour essayer la version soutien
tout le monde va courir après le soutien
de nicolas sarkozy bon maintenant avec
cette affaire c'est un peu compliqué ce
que je voulais dire simplement c'est que
par rapport à ces affaires judiciaires
il ya toujours eu un désamour très
important entre lui et le syndicat des
magistrats
sa date depuis le ministère de
l'intérieur il va faire de pornic en
2005 où c'était l'histoire d'un présumé
meurtrier lui la laddh il fallait le
condamné alors que les magistrats
l'avait libéré puis le maire a commencé
coup ça fait des années des années des
années qu'il est en guerre contre les
magistrats et la rigolade qui se venge
qui est un peu pour autant vous pouvez
pas non plus victimiser c'est à dire que
malgré tout il a été relaxé dans plein
d'affaires nicolas sarkozy vous êtes
d'accord donc la justice fonctionne bien
dans notre pays
monsieur cinéma encore ouvertes
notamment une fois encore grâce à
l'énergie kamil bnf et des juges et des
juges tournaire et puis sinon ça pose
quand même une question assez sérieuse
effectivement qui est celle que va
appeler qu'en 2017
l'élection présidentielle la cam était
un tout petit peu influencé que ça nous
plaise ou non vous constatez par par
l'éruption du du bnf dans cette affaire
sur le dossier sous le dossier fillon
c'est la première fois dans une affaire
de de présumés emplois fictifs ont
retenu la qualification de détournement
de fonds publics c'est une innovation à
trois mois des élections présidentielles
le pnf se permet d'innover et de mettre
en cause le candidat favori présidentiel
nicolas ce serait bien que les français
aient le droit que même de voter à
l'élection présidentielle indépendamment
des prescriptions de la justice marocain
s'allient pour vous c'est sévère pour
nicolas seube a oui parce que moi j'ai
un peu je me suis un peu documenté et
notamment le monde j'ai fait un article
très précis moment des auditions et qui
dit que clairement le dos il est
totalement vide
donc je veux c'est vrai que quand on lit
ça et qu'on comprend pourquoi quand il
ya un dossier qui est vide et que rien
n'est prouvé qu'ils auraient
éventuellement une intention prendre
trois ans de prison dont un an ferme et
moi je trouve que c'est joué sur sa cbr
oui franchement vraiment à savoir si
c'est ça pourrait être une manoeuvre
politique pour le museler l approche des
élections
on n'en sait rien tout est possible en
plus
on avait dit la même chose sur les
affaires dsk quelques années plusieurs
années après on a toujours trouvé aucun
fait qui sur qui affirme cette thèse
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que là ça nous paraître ça paraît à
beaucoup de gens trop ferme parce que
c'est tabou et c'est nouveau le fait
qu'on enferme maintenant des hommes
politiques ont encore voir voir un
président la république est depuis de
faire mal quand on sait que maintenant
que même un homme politique peut aller
entretenir la prison ferme
peut-être qu'il en fera aussi annoncé
stéphane dhabi non mais faut pas rentrer
dans la parano ou ses terres quelqu'un
aurait pris la décision d'appeler la
jugeons en dix ans condamné le c'est
potentiellement un candidat dangereux
pour nous ça n'existe pas là on est dans
les eaux néo sur les réseaux sociaux la
scène ça n'existe pas ça ne l'est pas il
ya beaucoup de ceux qui demandent à
consentir prendra mais ne serait-ce qu
aucun homme politique ne prendra le
risque d'appeler un juge d'instruction
ou un juge de sièges parce qu'il faut
faire la différence
alors il ya le pnf évidemment alors le
pen est déjà plein de gens qui disent
qu'elle se sait que peiné parce que le
pas non c'est qui instruit les dossiers
l'agenda financier qui avait été mis en
place par françois hollande est là et
bien s'apprécier qui a accusé sa demande
d'être à la solde de la gauche voilà de
l'opposant pour résumé voilà puisque
c'est lui qui met en place par françois
hollande salue mollahs est l'ailé tandis
que ça la solde de la gauche oui c'est
vrai que le président a souvent eu
affaire aux mêmes magistrats
mais le magistrat instructeur pas le
magistrat de sièges
il ya une grande différence entre le
magistrat instructeur et magistrats de
siège
il peut aller à l'encontre alors pour
rejoindre benjamin c'est vrai que il ya
beaucoup d'artistes y lisent qui a pas
grand chose dans le dossier si bien
qu'au dernier moment le parquet
financier a envoyé pour plaider le
premier procureur
du parquet financier j'ai été vraiment
derrière les buts juste m si ça avait
été quelqu'un d'autre que nicolas
sarkozy est ce que la peine moi la
question est simple pour vraiment que
tout le monde comprenne et pour que je
comprenne moi aussi est-ce qu'elle
aurait eu la même sanction
moi je peux pas me prononcer ce qu'un
magistrat aurait dû dire ou pas est-ce
que je pense que au niveau international
si on peut prendre un peu plus de
hauteur au jour avec les restrictions de
liberté et la démocratie qui est remis
en cause avec toutes les restrictions de
liberté qu'on a qui sont sans précédent
à voir aujourd'hui dans l'opinion
internationale la france un président de
la république qui est condamné je me
demande si c'est au nord les valeurs de
la république et l'image du pays
voilà pensé que c'était judiciaire pour
la france pour l'image la fondation
c'était déjà arrivé pour monsieur
chinois il faut pas que sarkozy les
emplois fictifs de la mairie de paris et
échappe à son procès il doit surtout
rendre compte devant la justice des
faits qui lui sont reprochés
mais alors j'interroge deux choses qui
est pas un début d'éléments qui
permettent de caractériser 7,7 cet acte
de corruption et le deuxième point c'est
qu'on se soit servi d' écoute et selon
moi tout à la loyale entre un avocat et
son duo téléspectateurs c'est à dire que
on s'est servi des gouttes qui s est pas
légal de faire son annonce olivier
marleix qui vous êtes député républicain
vice président des républicains est ce
que vous vous aimeriez que nicolas
sarkozy soit candidat en 2022 je pars en
fait tout pour lui donner envie
peut-être l'entourage de l'entourage
vous auriez envie vous dans les deux
doivent être jugés le grand attachement
équipements sont quasi mais pour nicolas
sarkozy
je suis pas sûr que ce soit d'actualité
du l'actualité du jour c'est pour moi
pour moi je vous dire pour moi c'est
l'actualité du jour bah oui en vrai en
vrai en lui des candidats ou pas norma
ci parce que la vraie question est que
tous les français se posent aujourd'hui
en est qui nous regardent en direct
c'est est ce que cette condamnation
elle va mettre des bâtons dans les roues
à voir nicolas sarkozy s'il préparait
peut-être une éventuelle candidature
ou bien est-ce qu'elle ne change rien et
si nicolas sarkozy veut se présenter en
2022 pas s'il se présentera et ça
changera rien face au ces et je vous dis
c'est un secret je crois que
tout le monde tous les républicains
enfin la majeure partie des républicains
cherchent un leader avec tout le monde
alors ils ont gagné bertrand qui est
dans les sondages plutôt plutôt même pas
mal passé il ya 15 de cette réaction
donc c'est plutôt bien vu qui s'en sort
bien 18 touchés tout le monde rêve tout
le monde rêve d'un retour de nicolas
sarkozy au sein de la droite où tout le
monde je suis pas quelqu'un qui est
certain c'est que nicolas sarkozy reste
la figure n'est plus le plus populaire à
droite la plus fédératrice dans
l'électorat de droite et cette décision
elle montre à travers et celle là puis
voulait pas encore toutes les enquêtes
mais été ouverte par le plf
il ya quelques semaines encore vous avez
eu un signalement de tracfin qui a donné
lieu à une ouverture d'enquêté ça tout
ça montre qu'effectivement la culture de
nicolas sarkozy
visiblement il fait peur alors ici à
certains et peut-être pouvoir en place
et est ce que ça ça peut être
préjudiciable pour lui pour sa
candidature si se présenter en 2022
malheureusement il a fait il a fait
preuve d'une énergie donc le fait qu'il
fasse peur effectivement semble
mobiliser quelques quelques personnes
contre lui et évidemment tout ça tout ça
tout ça n'est pas neutre il faut bien
avoir conscience
ça a déjà joué contre lui en 2000 en
2016 c'est ces enquêtes ouvertes dans la
dent lors de la primaire droite ça déjà
joué contre lui donc aujourd'hui
évidemment une question d'honneur pour
lui elle avait annoncé un calendrier
judiciaire et la bouillie a réagi c'est
une femme carla bruni s'est installée a
dit qu'il ya un acharnement
voilà contre nicolas sarkozy c'est ce
qui a twitté
car là est ce que la justice a mis à sac
hashtag injustice est ce qu'en tant que
femme bas les risques vous aimez ce
genre de prise de position là c'est à la
fois une prise de position personnelle
et une prise de position de première
dame l'ex première dame en tout cas sa
parole est une parole parole politique à
ce moment là en montrant son amour et en
montrant qu'elle est derrière nicolas
sarkozy s'est aussi non seulement une
femme qui aime son mari mais c'est
également une ex première dame qui dit
cet homme là ce président de la
république est innocent et moi je suis
toujours derrière cette expression de la
république super beau très courageux et
très émouvant à chaque fois le elle elle
tient avec beaucoup de ballons rouges
trop guillaume ya plein de gens qui
disaient qu'elle serait plus là quand
nicolas sarkozy n'est plus président
aulas le soutient plus que jamais c'est
pas la première fois que le soutien
public on vous pensez que carla
bruni-sarkozy et pousse nicolas sarkozy
un représentant
stéphane à wil inverse
elle est très heureuse comme aller
aujourd'hui c'est ça et puis nicolas
sarkozy fin il n'est pas hors jeu
aujourd'hui un grand nombre de députés
de président de région continue il s'en
sortit sentant plus exactement macro le
consul surpasser ça les deux il s'entend
très bien il se reçoivent ya pas de
problème moi j'ai reçu récemment carla
qui justement me disais qu'il n'y avait
aucun problème qui s'entend dire et
c'est là qu'il ya vraiment des gens qui
vont sur rfm je me sentais très bien
j'entendais très très bien et que
justement il se consultaient qui se
parlait beaucoup et que c'est paco
contrairement à ce qu'a dit monsieur
s'était pas du tout le pouvoir en place
qui se mêlent de quoi que ce soit pour
s'entendent assez bien le danger ne
vient pas de là monsieur bonnet retenir
il est adroit saison macron vient
plaider contre nicolas sarkozy
je m'interrogeais sur mes relations avec
avec celui qui a nommé monsieur monsieur
le maire que le pnf là mais quand vous
voyez aussi tous ceux de la droite qui
ont qui ont laissé des messages un peu
bizarre justement sur les condamnations
monsieur sarkozy les questions à se
poser aussi à droite gilles verdez
voulez moi je suis pas d'accord sur le
fond du dossier mais on peut se poser la
casse qui a quand même pacte de
corruption monsieur dans la condamnation
mais sur l'agenda judiciaire
on vous poser des questions le procès
des écoutes dans quinze jours le procès
bâillon à lyon avec son avocat qui a
fait appel monsieur herzog son avocat
historique qui a été condamné aussi et
qu'il y avait une scène d'interdiction
de la profession dont il n'aurait pas pu
s'il fait pas appel il peux pas le
défendre
non mais non mais s'il ne fait pas appel
il n'aurait pas pu regarder c'est parti
oui à 31% non à 69 %
voyez ou pas donc les gens pensent que
la peine n'est pas trop sévère à 69% mer